how are you doing sir
i'm good steve how are you i'm doing
excellent it's uh
it's a good day to be talking about a
great movie oh
thank you um i know that you're a huge
sorkin fan
just like all of us so i am i am curious
um how much did you pay to be in the
movie
a [ __ ] no um i i think i feel like i
just perhaps said enough times and
enough i've always wanted that thing
with actors when you do so much press
and if you say enough times that you
want to work with someone either they go
god that guy's lame would he stop trying
to get to work with me or
but on this particular occasion maybe it
worked i mean as you said i feel like
i've said in every interview ever that i
i'm obsessed with his work but when and
so when the script arrived
and i was offered the part before i'd
even read it i think i'd called my agent
and gone yeah and my agent was like no i
think you should probably uh
read it first but it was it was one of
the great joys but you've got to be
careful working with your heroes because
it can
it can um it can ruin things and i'm
thrilled to say that i loved every
minute of working with him he's a
special man
listen i i don't even think when when
the script says aaron sorkin on it
you know written by aaron sorkin i
really don't think you have to read it i
think
i think you could just commit you know
one of those things
um listen watching the film you can't
help but get angry
at what was depict i mean what really
happened and what this
judge did and unfortunately it's so
similar
i think to what's going on now that if
you have the wrong people
in control um it can get really bad
can you sort of talk about the
timeliness of this film which you
couldn't have realized when you were
making it it was going to be
just so timely no i think i mean the
film's been the script was written 15
years ago and
there have been many different um
versions of
castes and directors and and i just when
i read the script and i
knew nothing about this period of
history
but found it so extraordinary as a
thrilling piece of drama that i couldn't
understand how it had not been made
and i think maybe it was like is there
an audience you know and the answer
was that since we made the film as you
say it's become
like scarily and eerily
you know so back in in 68 you had
you know the vietnam war being protested
but you had um
the civil rights movement you had the
women's rights movement the following
year you had stonewall
you had uh you know a
an ex-vice president trying to become
president you had a flu pandemic it was
it's i hope that the the urgency of the
film for me is that
that you know how we as a race
and and as countries because the whole
world is watching what america does
um how we've evolved and how we haven't
evolved and and how important it is to
to take stock of our history and and to
not
repeat our mistakes great job and
congrats on being part of on such a
great movie thank you